Business is bad for carpenter Nazir Ahmad
and his employee Abdul Satar.
Along with international military units leaving
Afghanistan,
many foreign aid workers have also left.
Since those departures, Ahmad hasn't had many
orders.
On top of that, the overall security situation
in Kabul has worsened significantly.
"I am always scared.
When I leave the house in the morning I often
ask myself if I'll come home alive.
I'm scared for my wife and my children - they
could also be killed by a bomb.
We are constantly in danger."
Kabul looks like a fortress now.
Police checkpoints are everywhere.
Politicians, warlords, ambassadors and aid
organizations barricade themselves behind
massive concrete walls designed to withstand
bomb attacks.
They often hire private security firms to
patrol their compounds.
Very few want to rely on the city's poorly
trained and often corrupt police officers.
"Kabul has been the target of seven major
attacks so far this year.
That’s more than at any time since the intervention
started.
Even with a modest increase in military assistance
by the United States or its partners, experts
predict that the situation will only get worse."
People in Kabul are extremely frustrated about
the situation.
Many blame their own government for not being
able to disarm the warlords and their militias.
"Our government can't do anything - how are
they supposed to bring peace?"
"Nobody can help Afghanistan more than its
own people -- so they have to stand up
and fight for Afghanistan."
We hear again and again that an Afghan solution
would also require reconciliation
with the Taliban.
But it's not that easy.
Mohammed Qasim Halimi worked for the Taliban
regime of Mullah Omar for years.
Now he works for the new government's religious
council -
yet still keeps in contact with the Taliban.
"I can say that 80 percent of the Taliban
want to negotiate with the Afghan government.
They want to solve the problem, they want
to stop the war -- but some of them
don’t want to negotiate, and they are actually
the ones who have the power."
We also asked carpenter Nazir Ahmad why he
thinks the government hasn't been able to
unite the country.
Like many frustrated Afghans, he doesn't have
an answer.
But he's sure that building up military might
is NOT the solution.
"I don't think that more international troops
here would accomplish anything.
What did they achieve when 130 thousand soldiers
were here?
And if they send a couple of thousand over
now - so what?"
Ahmad hopes that the international community,
in cooperation with the Afghan government,
will create more jobs.
That would help to prevent radical groups
from taking advantage of disaffected youth.
Ahmad says better job prospects would
bring more security to this war-torn land.